[Music]
today's question comes from jim in
arizona due to a recent divorce my
credit was ruined and retirement wiped
out i've been able to start restoring my
score currently at 6 40. i want to get
my credit back up to over 700 so i can
buy another home i have three thousand
dollars in debt on a vehicle payment and
i'm paying off medical debt now under
two thousand dollars i want to do the
baby steps but i need the debt to
rebuild credit to buy a new home
where do i start well george you would
be homeless yeah 100 percent
this is a very interesting legendary not
homeless george me too
how can you get a home without a credit
score dave have you ever talked about
this in 30 years uh
the best example i can think of is you
you did it yes how did you do that
george i did it uh well it's it's a
fancy process called manual underwriting
it's very old-timey they look at your
real financial life like your income
like they like to see if you can
actually pay the payments
just like that oh man that's wicked and
you have to send in a few utility bills
say hey look i pay things on time i'm
reliable you can trust me and then they
go okay here's a mortgage
and a lot of people uh you know i've got
some flat because we did an episode on
the credit score called the dirty truth
behind your credit score and one of the
things the fine print podcast on the
fine print podcast and one of the things
we attacked was this idea that you need
a credit score to get a mortgage and we
talked to our friend seth over at
churchill mortgage and he walked us
through the process and a lot of people
are freaked out to go it's so difficult
and your interest rate's going to be so
much higher
and i can tell you from someone who's
done it that none of that is true it's
not difficult and your interest rate's
not higher liar
you you you liar person you that's right
so to jim in arizona this idea that and
he said it himself but i need the debt
to rebuild credit well he has believed
the lie and jim's not the liar but he
believed the lie that's out there that
people like that were giving you a hard
time about the fine print thing because
it's fine current podcast because
here's the thing the lie is
that the great provider in your life is
the great god fico
and if you worship at the altar of the
great god fico and continue to bring him
offerings of interest
by paying payments on your debt
repeatedly he will raise
his eyes to you bestoweth upon you he
will he will bestoweth upon you a
greater score
because you have earned your way talk
about legalism you've earned your way
there's no grace in this you've earned
your way into the great god fico's
presence by
borrowing lots of money and paying it
back so we borrow money why
so we can pay payments why
so we can get a higher score why
so we can borrow money why so we can pay
payments wide so we can get a higher
score why so we can get pay payments so
we can get more debt so it's a dog
chasing its tail building banks with
bank money
and they took it from
it's not you
no this is like sisyphus just pushing up
the rock every day trying to build his
score back up and here's the thing it
goes back to the gamification we talked
about with credit card rewards it feels
good to have a good score you feel like
this is my scoreboard for my financial
life but the true scoreboard is not
having debt
and having a high net worth
that's what it's about and so to do that
jim here's what's going to happen you're
going to pay off your debt and after
probably six months or so your credit
score will become indeterminable make
sure you have no debt accounts of any
kind of inactive close them off none
active they're all paid off even if
you've got some old bad debt go clean it
up all accounts are closed and then your
little 640 score will go poofy
and disappear and you will be a zero
you'll be incredible and george is a
zero yeah it's okay to be zero
we talked about this in the on the
stupid score your credit invisible and i
want to get a zero on your stupid score
yes
and uh you know just like i was
invisible to girls in high school you
will become invisible with your credit
history
that's what's gonna happen
you'll disappear no one will see you in
the credit world when they look up your
account
did that hurt that one you felt that
and it's bad
i know yeah it's fine i'm married up now
i'm doing great i'm doing much better
guys thank you for asking yeah well
you're just a regular sex symbol now
that's right oh my gosh so unbelievable
back to jim's question buddy you don't
need to rebuild your score the 640 is
gonna go away after you've had no debt
your accounts are closed and then you
can work with a reputable mortgage
company like churchill mortgage there's
others that do this people act like
they're just not out there just you just
can't get around without debt son don't
you know oh oh
the culture talking down to you let me
tell you what happened to me 1988 to
file bankruptcy right
28 years old dumber than a rock
obviously because i filed bankruptcy
because i was an idiot because i got too
far in debt and i don't know what i'm
doing i got a finance degree but i'm
dumber than a rock doesn't work right
these days you'd be a tick-tock star
date
so well there you go
uh that means that
no i have no response to that so um
anyway
my bankruptcy attorney
gave me financial advice
now this should give you pause to start
with right but not me i'm dumb enough i
took it he said so you need to go the
first thing you need to do is you need
to rebuild your credit after bankruptcy
because a chapter 7 bankruptcy just
wipes you out baby i mean your credit's
just destroyed all you got on there is
all these negative things and
everything's going to be on there for
seven years except your chapter seven
bankruptcy which is going to be on there
10 years
oh goody
he goes so you need to build some
positive credit immediately i'm like so
how do i do that who's going to loan a
bankrupt full money
now this is 1988. you know he said do go
sign up for today's version would be
online but in those days it was analog
go sign up and order and subscribe to
every
financial magazine
as soon as you do you'll start getting
pre-approved credit cards in your
mailbox
start using those and you will rebuild
your credit
hack it completely worked wow
i got credit cards coming out my ears in
about six months after filing bankruptcy
they came in just like
you know just like taking candy from a
baby
and that and it wasn't long after that
that i woke up and realized uh wait a
minute i'm doing the same stupid butt
stuff that got me here in the first
place and this is you're a dumb boy you
just do the same dumb thing over and
over again and so we had a little
plastic surgery party and i uh no longer
take financial advice from bankruptcy
attorneys which
is dumb enough to do that to start with
he wants you back in his office in a few
years apparently i want to be in this
yeah i'm going to be a regular customer
wow unbelievable good stuff there
but i mean that's it's the same thing
it's it's the same lie
that if you tell a lie loud enough often
enough and long enough it's called
propaganda
and eventually the entire culture
believes the lie to where if you say the
sky is blue they say no it's not
you know and if you say you know don't
jump off a building you'll hit the
sidewalk no law gravity doesn't apply
you know and and
but people believe this crap yeah i
always say my credit was ruined so how
do i fix my rune credit go get more
credit you got to get it
i tell people dave if you follow the
trends you will fall for the traps and
the credit score is one of these trends
thank you it took me a while to tweet
that but it's one of those things that
the credit score has been this trend for
so many years where we're telling 17 18
year olds you got to build your credit
you got to build your credit you're
going to need it for the rest of your
life
and the the problem is the parents they
believe what they're saying because
they're dumb too
i was that dumb person i went and i just
told you my dumb story oh my god we've
all done done so listen if we just can't
call stupid stupid we got a problem oh
wait a minute we got a problem because
now it's illegal to call to just say
what you hurt my feelings dave
you have them
see there we go all right there we go i
didn't know georgetown had depleted all
of my feelings i thought i thought we
had a feeling ectomy
this is the ramsey show